good morning believe nation today's
message is stand behind what you do over
to you
Kendrick Lamar it's a whole world out
there man that believes and what you can
do and what you can say and the energy
you bring you know I'm not if you just
justify myself a lot of people have
their own different niche and you know
you have to be a super lyricist or story
to it just be the energy to bring think
I'm saying they believe in it but the
moment they feel like you don't believe
in that no more and you're just going
with the next trend where there's a
Thwaites where there's a up-tempo slow
tomorrow - exactly
they don't believe it you know more you
know the coach you don't believe you
know more so stand behind what you do
and you know the world is gonna move by
and that's acting I look at so what do
you think oh I totally agree I agree
with Kendrick authenticity integrity
standing for what you do belief
confidence these are like super powerful
traits and if you want to accomplish
anything I feel like they're gee I look
at the website that I had and one of the
biggest frustrations that I had was just
trying to chase views and just trying to
do the things that I thought would get
me a lot of views cuz you're chasing ad
dollars it started to feel super empty
and I lost a lot of the love for what I
was doing because it didn't feel like I
was creating things that were really
meaningful just what was hot and so yes
we look at profiling people that might
be in the news but the content that I'm
putting out now just feels right like
it's stuff that I'm passionate about
it's stuff that we're still pouring a
lot of love and energy into and I think
there is a danger of if you're just
trying to follow the trend but you're
not actually excited about what it is
just trying to make bank then you're not
gonna have a lot of success you're not
gonna feel the energy behind it and
you're not gonna get the results or
impact that you're looking for
so the question today today is name
something you stand behind what do you
stand behind leave it in the comments
below and we will join in the discussion
so thank you guys so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
or whatever your one word is and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso
so the question so the question today
today is keep me up a dancer yeah that's
a good question